[Musica]
una sera buonasera
l'asma proprio per questo giovane comico
questo giovane uomo buonasera a tutti
buona serata
allora lui e wiston churchill nel 1940
divenne primo ministro di inghilterra fu
un politico carismatico dotato di un
estrema intelligenza senza ombra di
dubbio fu un politico dotato di un fu
anche un estremo un ottimo stratega
infatti fu tra quei personaggi che
sconfissero aiutarono a debellare il
nazismo durante la seconda guerra
mondiale ecco non tutti sanno che
quest'uomo wiston churchill soffriva di
depressione
il numero che ne racconta la sua
biografia infatti si racconta di come
passasse durante tutta la sua vita
politica e non enormi e bui periodi
chiuso in camera
questa storia è famosa e conosciuta come
la storia del cane nero di cerci
lui diceva che questo cane non era
facile da addomesticare non era un cane
fedele non gli riportava in giro
indietro il basso una volta che gli
aveva rilanciato questo cane faceva
quello che voleva quando lo voleva
prendendosi gioco della sua intelligenza
ecco questo chi un ottimo parallelismo
della depressione se ci pensate per che
infatti non è possibile addomesticarla
tenerla sotto controllo anche le più
semplici e positive intenzioni vengono
completamente annientate da questo cane
nero
cerci sconfisse i nazisti e questo
comunque delinea il profilo di una
persona sicura porte che non si lascia
troppo trasportare dagli eventi eppure
avevamo un momento della sua vita
la cosa che contava era la nera il
potere è una cosa che non contava non
era il potere non era la politica e
discorsi l'unica cosa che davvero aveva
senso era questo cane da un certo punto
bussava la sua porta si faceva dare a
mangiare dare da mangiare una volta
finito quello che c'era nella ciotola
gli devastava completamente la casa
ora questo racconto è un libro realmente
scritto da nessuna parte ho trovato il
tipo la razza di questo cane così
stasera mi sono preso il diritto di
poterlo mostrare per farvi capire quale
bestia
abbiamo a che fare
il cane nero di churchill
era vincere
dietro quel muso tanto tenero cessata la
buona sera a tutti io sono simone ho 30
anni e credo di essere una persona
normale qualsiasi cosa questa normalità
voglia dire nel senso che faccio rider
consegno il cibo a domicilio o un
secondo lavoro che sto cercando di
trasformare nel primo che a quello del
videomaking ma per il resto non sono una
persona di qualsiasi qualche particolare
intelligenza non sono uno che legge
molto ma questo me ne renderete conto
dai pessimi congiunti che utilizzerò in
questo monologo
e o anche testimonianze a riguardo del
fatto che non penso di aver mai
sconfitto nemmeno una volta in vita mia
un nazista difficilmente finché una
discussione contro la mia ragazza e chi
la conosce e sa che ogni tanto dentro di
lei si nasconda il fiore
ha fatto allo stop lauso dai su facciamo
lo stop la line
[Applauso]
di conseguenza l'unica cosa che potevo
prendere dal personaggio del calibro di
cerci poteva solo che essere la
depressione e vabbè un principio di
calvizie insomma avete capito che avete
davanti questa sera
questo sono io a 25 anni
pesavo 120 kg questa mia mamma che sta
ridendo
essendosi siete
questo sono io c è quanto ha 25 anni
pensavo 120 kg e avevo raggiunto quel
peso piano senza accorgermene
e per il risultato di mesi anni dove
avevo allontanato la mia famiglia gli
amici l'amore
o in kg preso aveva il peso di tristezza
di inadeguatezza di ansia di fobie
sociali di stress di paure di pizza
una quantità infinita di pizza consiglio
mio personale a toni cipolle con una
manciata di rucola crudo a morte sua mai
fatelo cos'è sta timidezza mai
[Applauso]
e quindi ero chiuso da quattro anni
ormai nella mia camera e tutto quello
che facevo era semplicemente guardare la
vita attraverso lo schermo di un
computer tutto quello che mi andava di
fare era soltanto mangiare chiedermi
sotto le coperte e spera di non dover
uscire mai
la cosa assurda è quando uscivo di casa
sorridevo sempre facciamo finta che le
cose andassero bene ero avete presente
quegli omicidi che finiscono poi dalla
d'urso quelli efferati da un certo punto
c'è l'intervistatrice che va a cercare
informazioni è avvicinato e puntualmente
un vicino gli risponde con signora tour
somala ma simone ma non l'avrei mai
detto io di simone ma salutava e
sorrideva sempre
salutava e sorrideva sempre
fatti non avreste mai detto ma che cos'è
questa depressione ma lancia non c'è la
slide alla depressione è una deviazione
del comportamento in senso malinconico
con sintomi che ne compromettono la
socialità la sessualità e l'umore in
modo che va dal ii va grave nella
persona che ne soggetta fine una delle
malattie perché più complesse che solo
in italia paralizza quasi 4 milioni di
persone e questo senza considerare
lockdown chiusa in tre righe di testo in
corsivo
questa deprimente
vuoi la viola definizione di depressione
simone dopo un tipo depressione e alle
persone eccentrici ritrovi senza capire
mai bene nel come nel perché ad un certo
punto sei più piccolo lontano dal tuo
corpo e tutto intorno a te ovattato
anche le più piccole faccende sono
motivo di forte ansia
ti senti insicuro alti sentite voleex
enti strano
un'aura negati circonda e tutto intorno
a te è un continuato criticarsi il ds
sbagliato vi guardate allo specchio
dirti che fai schifo
ti senti contagioso come se quell'aura
di pesci nera potesse poi contagiare
anche gli altri la cosa subdola infame
che può in qualche modo contagia sempre
che ti sta vicino
devo tantissimo l'incomprensione credevo
volevo essere speciale ma la verità è
che ero solo un mediocre la scuola
facevo schifo lavoro non ottenevo chissà
quale risultato di 0 0 passioni le cose
che facevo era stare fermo a guardare
gli altri che andavano avanti
guardavo né altre persone mi chiedevo ma
com'è possibile che le vostre vite siano
così perfette e come com'è possibile che
voi non sentiate anche soltanto un
minimo di questa angoscia come
è la cosa che nessuno ti dice che la
depressione fa male cazzo formale come
se fosse un dolore fisico
quando faccio delle pause così perché
non mi sono dimenticato cosa devo dire
[Applauso]
ovviamente era una pausa per la pausa ho
chiesto comunque del sostegno
psicologico ma con quel percorso non
sono stato molto fortunato
magari non sono stato bravo io in
qualche modo a farmi a dare la giusta
chiave di lettura che mi ascoltava
magari non erano competenti loro fatto
sta che mi sono ritrovato con delle
pastiglie che bloccavano i miei pensieri
che vedevano la mia vita piatta
apatica
non chiedetemi cosa voglia dire apatico
cervello
e faccio una premessa le medicine da
alcuni casi servono al medicina in
alcuni casi tengono insieme i pezzi che
altrimenti non ce la farebbero stare
insieme ma per quello che mi riguarda
per quanto pensare così tanto pensare
così brutto potesse far male ritrovarmi
a non pensare assolutamente niente
e stato anche peggio
oggi ho capito che nella depressione ci
arrivi
piano piano quando nè consapevolezza
capisci che sono soltanto dei punti che
si uniscono per ognuno ovviamente
diverso può essere causata da tantissime
cose può essere causata da alcuni disagi
dall utilizzo di sostanze da dipendenze
da
un'infinità di cose abusi violenze per
quello che mi riguarda qualcosa si era
rotto
tra l'essere un ragazzino pieno di
capelli
che giocava videogames che
credeva di essere speciale e credeva
conte non avrebbe dimostrato al mondo un
ragazzino che guardare film d'amore e ci
credeva bestia
e tra la realtà invece che era che i
videogiochi era un po da sfigati
ritrovare alla ragazza a scuola la mia
iperattività veniva scambiata per voglia
di rompere sono le palle quindi via di
note di presidenza le mie emozioni
iniziavano con le migliori premesse
romantiche finivano con le peggiori
scene drammatiche
chiuso poi con delle compagnie con cui
non condivido più nulla se non il solito
burrell ubriacarmi per soffocare
pensieri
tutto questo in più per altro circondato
da questa sensazione che soltanto chi ha
vissuto in una provincia come verbania
riesce a capire una sensazione di
doversi per forza omologare agli altri
di non poter essere se stessi perché
qualcuno ti osserva
prima di chiudermi in quella camera ho
finito che ritrovarmi insicuro
sempre sentendomi un pesce fuori
dall'acqua
e solo
parlerò di suicidio semplicemente perché
voglio dirvi che
chiunque abbia sofferto di pressione
qualche modo si è ritrovato a pensare
alla morte al suicidio una buona per
cento delle persone che pensano suicidio
idealizzano al fatto che la morte è
l'unica soluzione alle proprie
alternative ai propri problemi
oggi una buona parte di quelle persone
non c'è più
voglio che ve lo immaginate
siete su un palazzo molto in alto
davanti a voi c'è il vuoto più totale
e dietro vivo ci sono problemi le ansie
le paure che li spingono vi spingono vi
spingono e voi lo fate quel passo
niente più oggi niente più domani
mentre più ieri
chiunque ha sofferto di depressione si
trova a pensare al suicidio ma io sono
stato fortunato sono stato la persona
che ha sempre creduto che un giorno le
cose sarebbero andate meglio un
ottimista
ma voglio che sappiate
che questa se avrei potuto non essere
qui
e io questo senso questo questo silenzio
lo sento sono dentro le vostre teste
che in questo momento state pensando ma
come è uno spoiler questo ma come ivo
aveva detto che erano comico dove sono
le nostre esatte ti prego di una
barzelletta qualcosa ti prego
voglio soltanto che sappiate che la
depressione
ti si tratta per sempre fottutamente
addosso la depressione non passa con una
cioccolata calda non passa con una pacca
sulla spalla né tantomeno pensando che
là fuori c'è chi sta peggio perché è
ovvio là fuori c'è chi sta peggio ma non
è nella protesta alla sera quando te ne
vai a dormire
voglio che vi arrivi il fatto che la
depressione ti si tappa per sempre cazzo
fottutamente addosso
come state
come vi sentite
già lasciamo le cinture perché adesso
signori andiamo ancora più in fondo nel
momento di quella foto decisi che era
arrivato il momento di uscire dalla mia
camera ero stanco volevo riprendermi in
mano la vita
così mi scrisse in palestra persi 30 kg
mia passione alla bicicletta persi tutti
i miei capelli
viaggiai andai da barcellona finale
valentia e poi partiti da qui da
verbania andai fino a roma da solo in
bicicletta una delle avventure più
incredibili della mia vita
apri un canale comico su youtube che da
quello che potete capire non è proprio
la professione ideale
[Musica]
non voglio vederli giu le luci non
voglio vederlo
mi iscrissi a scuola l'anno scorso mi
sono incredibilmente diplomato
e in quel momento andava bene andava
tutto bene essere sincera andava tutto
bene in quel momento ho ricevuto in
faccia allo schiaffo di verità doloroso
che io abbia mai ricevuto
ho capito che avrei potuto perdere altri
30 kg
avrei potuto laurearmi avrei potuto
diventare il miglior comico del mondo
probabilmente avrei potuto finalmente
vincere una sola anche solo uno i servi
della stata discussione contro la mia
ragazza
ma non ha mai ma non avrei mai vinto
contro la depressione
e cerci race il cerci sconfisse i
nazisti
e io chi sono
ora
nel 2017 il 31 dicembre
precisamente
torna in un buio non uno dei momenti
forse più bui della mia vita fece una
cosa strana scrissi una lettera in
questa lettera scrivo di come mi sentivo
che ero depresso che mi dispiaceva avere
allontanato tutti quanti che non stavo
bene
che mi dispiaceva
e quello che è successo qualcosa di
inaspettato
era dieci anni che non mi sentivo così
leggero
aver scritto quella lettera averla poi
pubblicata sui social network mi ha
fatto sentire meglio
perché mi scrissero un sacco di persone
ma un altro un'altra fetta di persone
scrissero dei messaggi privati di storie
come la mia ed è assurdo quando la
repressione ti faccia sentire solo e di
quanto anche con questa merda soli non
lo si è mai
ho capito
che tutto si riduce nel capire
che non è tanto lo scappare dalla
repressione combattere
tutto si riuscirà a capire che quando di
persone soltanto saper condividi con
vivere
anche se sai che questa non si pagherà
mai l'affitto
ho capito che mostrare le mie debolezze
non mi rende debole non starai le mie
stranezze niente speciale
non allontana alle persone anzi ha
permesso dei genitori di ritrovare un
figlio permesso a degli amici di
avvicinarsi anche se faccio ancora un
sacco di fatica vicini a loro ha
premesso a quella che reputo oggi essere
la donna più incredibile è speciale del
mondo e farmi capire che cos'è l'amore
ti amo
no no no non
è perché mi sento in un video quindi
probabilmente in questo punto detto ti
amo tonino il carrozziere non so dove
sei
alza la mano e
non vorrei mai ringraziare la
depressione davvero non hai mai per
niente farlo ma è anche vero che tutto
quello che ho passato mi ha portato a
essere qui questa sera davanti a voi sul
ted
a lanciare un messaggio che spero che in
qualche modo possa aiutarvi
parlate di depressione fate capire al
mondo che siete depressi ditte quanto
questa merda faccia schifo
scrivete salute scrivete una lettera
fate una cosa per nulla traumatica come
salire su un palco
chiedete aiuto piangete permettere alle
persone di avvicinarsi farà male sarà la
cosa più dolorosa della post ragazzo di
vita
ma la leggerezza la leggerezza che
arriverà dopo tanto peso
quella l'opera toglierà nessuno
grazie
[Applauso]